back at the studio two chains and pop
star Paloma Ford are kicking it with
Master G the original Rat MC the first
time anyone heard rap on a record it was
his voice and people lost their bloody
Minds talk about a showstopper they're
joined by a national hip-hop museum
curator Jeremy Bieber to check out some
Priceless pieces of rap history yeah all
right two chains my friend okay Paloma
nice to meet you okay well let's get it
started and you know I'm the first
originally commercially successful
Robert in don't play with you oh okay
I'm just saying tell them first and you
know
don't play this camera I don't know yeah
commercially first successful hip-hop
artist in the world
started right here Sugar Hill Gang
Rapper's Delight right here Master g wow
actually that's a great segue yes can I
show you something about the Sugar Hill
Gang we're gonna show you some stuff
okay all right I'm I'm ready okay
well you got to put gloves on that's
what I'm saying he's got his curated
gloves oh my God one of the interesting
things I know when it's a win this cap
if they put gold on it there's some cap
and if they put gloves on it to handle
it it's some cash real so we have the
largest collection of hip-hop artifacts
and memorabilia in the world
foreign
okay so we're the world's first hip-hop
Museum we're located in Washington DC
the world's first hip-hop Museum doesn't
just preserve and collect we also need
to educate
so I think Master G might be the first
one to tell you so what an eight-track
is
back in the day okay it was like a box
and you put this in the Box
and this is how the music was played so
this is at my first album this is
literally my first that's me right there
that's him let me see you right there
that's him
that's beautiful that's him
yeah so that's literally the first Sugar
Hill baby this is
crazy this is another one this is our
greatest hits album but it's the same
idea and that's what you kept and you
are yeah
the original I'm the original order
original hoarder brother is this this
before vinyls no so it's right around it
so it's vinyl eight-track that was all
during that time okay yeah then this is
like a video game
it's the same idea
but it played music there were only four
hip-hop releases ever released on eight
track those are two of the four right
two of the four so 10 miles slow down
slowly
is this what Lee people to make museums
have in this type of historic stuff yes
put okay yes this is the reason why like
this preservation of the culture okay
yeah because you in order to know how to
get where you got to go you got to
understand where you came from this
right here is the beginning of our music
literally how could you possibly sell
check this out the boxing glove
from LL Cool J's Mama Said Knock You Out
music video we definitely aware of this
for real yeah man is this the one he was
wearing
this is a video one of the videos yeah
and how did y'all get this piece of
History done because see you didn't this
is not your song finally we're done with
you
you're so shy because I'm really yeah I
really don't want to get it out there
but you know um well I can I can tell
you something I'll show you something
that most people wouldn't notice on this
uh what most people would notice is
if you flip it over
actually been authenticated this is
what's called a JSA Authentication and
what this means is that this article
this artifact has provenance it has been
authenticated to be the actual article
and therefore an appraisal company is
willing to State their name on it
it's sticker to me man
not gonna lie it does look like a
sticker and so because this is the only
one known to mankind
um it has been appraised for 75 to 95
thousand dollars
so maybe you've heard of a record label
Called Death Row perhaps
this is a one of one Jeff Hamilton
handmade leather jacket for Suge Knight
in honor
of doggies wow
that's hard that's Jeff Hamilton one of
the greatest leather makers he is the
best at making these jackets absolutely
shout out to Jeb Hamilton this is a
original sug jacket bro wow man
the details so crazy crazy black is
crazy so hard I'm from Long Beach so oh
there you go on behalf of on behalf of
Long Beach on behalf of Long Beach we
endorse this amazing right fully but the
significance of this jacket represents
their relationship
and there's no more iconic artifact than
this jacket to represent that kind of
tumultuous relationship and there is no
price tag for it
but it has been appraised
between 200 and 250 thousand dollars
serious business right I want that bad
[Laughter]
by the late 80s many people around the
country and the world considered this
next artist
one of the greatest if not the greatest
MC of all time in fact they even gave
them the title
the god MC and that's of course Rakim
the one and only Rakim where I can and
this is Dapper Dan that's Gucci yes
and he made that before his deal with
Gucci and Rakim is like man he's like
people's favorite rapper absolutely rap
it's one of my favorite you know what
I'm saying he's one of my favorite yeah
he's definitely the rappers rapper yeah
yeah did he wear that in any video or
something like that oh yeah so this is
the paid in full jacket and if you go on
YouTube that's the paid in full jacket
so the rock Kim jacket is one of one
these are American history and so you're
looking at about 125 to 150 000.
wow
but wait there's more
[Laughter]
another some story first of all duke it
has you I mean ever heard compared any
type of DNA test Weird Al Yankovic ever
Al Yankovic you ever been compared to Al
Yankovic I haven't
[Music]
you want to do something a little
special because we have some gifts for
you we have gifts
this is this is something that we do to
honor the most important hip-hop legends
that this country has ever turned out
which you are one of them by the power
vested in me
by the world's first hip-hop Museum the
national hip-hop Museum I honor you two
chains with the award of induction there
you go
um this is so cool thank you
thank you thank God man thank you man
y'all
yes yes and you deserve it brother I'm
the executive director come on now the
significance man the impact what you've
done for the culture that's hard
absolutely all right yeah it's more
important to be recognized by your peers
than it is by a bunch of old white guys
that don't know anything about him
[Music]
oh that sounds like a shot was fired
all right so we have to carry this one
in a specialized bulletproof briefcase
because
the insurance policy requires that it be
protected at all times
the cherry on top yes
very significant
[Music]
the actual demo tape yeah you need to
get in on this one from Fear of a Black
Planet Public Enemy
from Green Street recording studio where
the album was actually recorded that is
a pre-album demo of
full length
yes
that cassette tape may not function I'm
sure in the next five ten years so the
only way to allow it to live on is to
digitize the audio digitalizing it
digitized digitized I said what does
that say digital live yeah I probably
that word up
are those the same word digitize or
digitalized y'all look it up at home
because see guess what are we higher
I'm definitely high but listen y'all at
home
working so look it up
[Music]